- Alex Jones est un complotiste
notoire qui a fondé Infowars,
un site où il diffuse, depuisdes
toutes plus insensées
les unes que les autres.
(en anglais)
"Les attentats du 11 septembre,
une fabrication
des gouvernements."
(en anglais)
"Les démocrates,
des organisateurs
de réseaux pédophiles."
Mais l'un des pires faits
d'armes d'Alex Jones concerne
la tuerie de Sandy hook en 2012.
(en anglais)
"Une fusillade, dit-il,
qui est une pure invention,
avec des parents qui ne sont que
deacacteurs payés et des enfants
qui n'ont jamais existé."
Dans ce premier
de trois procès intentéscontre s
des victimes, il s'est retrouvé
confronté à ses mensonges,
avec le témoignage de
la mère du petit Jesse,
tué dans la fusillade.
"Pensez-vous que je suis
une actrice?" demande Scarlett
Lewis. "Non", répond-il.
Cru a aussi fut
le témoignage de Neil Heslin,
le père de Jesse.
"Mon fils a bel et bien existé,
dit-il, et j'ai été béni
de le voir vivre pendant
6 ans et demi."
Face à ce réquisitoire,
Alex Jones reconnaît que
la fusillade a eu lieu.
- It's a 100 % real...
- Mais trop peu, trop tard,
disent les parents,
qui demandent 150 millions
de dollars en compensation
pour la détresse émotionnelle
infligée intentionnellement.
- Twelve days ago,
your attorneys messed up...
- Il reste qu'hier,
l'avocat des victimes a lâché
une véritable bombenen cour.
L'avocat d'Alex Jones
lui a envoyé par mégarde
une copie numérique
de tous ces messages reçus
et envoyés s son téléphone.
- And that is how
I know you lied to me.
- Des messages qu'Alex Jones
disait ne pas avoir reçu
en spopossession.
- See, I told you the truth.
- Do you know what perjury is?
- "Comprenez-vous ce qu'est
le parjure?", demande l'avocat
àà un Alex Jones, médusé.
- Yes, I do!
- Des courriels et textos
que voudrait bien obtenir
aussila commission d'enquê
sur l'insurrection
du 6 janvier 2021,
car Alex Jones était l'un des
organisateurs d'un rassemblement
de partisans. Ses écngnges de
messages pourraient incriminer
certains hauts responsables.
- Ils vont voir qu'il a menti
à notre gouvernement.
- Son ex-femme, Kelly Jones,
qui se bat devant les tribunaux
pour la garde de leurs enfants,
veut aussi obtenir ces messages
divulgués; elle croit
que ses connexions avec
le 6 janvier seront dévoilées.
KELLY JONES,
ex-femme dlelex Jones
- Il y avait un certain groupe
de personnes qui aidaient Trump
qui étaient en contact avec lui
plusieurs fois, je suis sûre!
-  j jury a finalement décidé
d'octroyer 4 millions de dollars
en dommages à la famille
qui poursuivait Alex Jones,
ce qui est très loin
des 150 millions espérés.
Mais le complotiste est loin
d'en avoir fini avec la juste.e.
Ici Frédéric Arnould,
Radio-Canada, Washingto